>> So actually that was all we were going to talk about in this
lesson about computational learning theory. So let's
just recap where we went so far.
>> Okay. So what? You want me to do it?
>> Yeah, that's been our technique all along.
>> Fine. So here you're the teacher and I'm the student. I get
that. Which is actually one of the things that we talked about. Aha.
>> We talked about what it would mean
to be a learnerversus being a teacher. And how
teachers and learners interact to make learning happen faster or not.
>> Okay.
>> But that was actually in a larger
context which I thought was kind of cool which
was this sort of notion of trying to
understand what is actually learnable. Right and I think
the comparison that made sense to me was
that we were trying to do the equivalent to
what we do in computer science with complexity theory
and algorithms. While here we were bouncing up from
a specific algorithm like decision trees or. KNN and asking
a question about how fundamentally hard is the problem of learning.
>> Good.
>> And you know, like that. And we focused on a particular
measure of difficulty, which I guess drove everything else, so we talked
about which was sampled before it was excepted. Okay, how many examples,
how many samples do we need in order to learn some concept?
>> Good yeah, that's a really powerful idea because it's
a different resource than what's normally
studied in computer science, things like
time and space. This is now how much data do we need?
>> Right, which makes sense because we do machine learning
and machine learning people, what we care about is data.
>> I, I saw a t-shirt recently that says data is the new bacon.
>> Mm. So you're saying data is delicious?
>> Yeah, I think we like data a lot.
>> I love data. Okay, so that ties us
back into a discussion about teachers and students because what
we talked about was how If the relationship between the teacher and
the student was one way versus another way, we might get different
answers about sample complexity. So in particular, we talked about what would
happen in a world where the learner had to ask all the questions.
>> And that's powerful because the learner knows what
the learner doesn't know but the learner doesn't know
what the learner needs to know. So that is
somewhat powerful. But it may be useful for the teacher
to be more involved.
>> Right, so that's the other thing, where
the teacher, gets to actually pick the questions.
>> Great.
>> And then the third sort of case was where.
The teacher didn't really pick the questions or the teacher
didn't have an intent to pick the questions, but the
teacher was, in fact, nature, so like a fixed distribution.
>> Yeah, good.
>> Right. And some of those are,
you know, easier to deal with than others, like the teacher, since the
teacher knows the answer, can ask exactly the right set of questions and
get you there very quickly versus, say, when the teacher is just nature.
And, you know, you get it according
to whatever distribution there happens to be.
>> Sort of oblivious, maybe, is a better word.
>> I think unfeeling.
>> Nature just doesn't care about me.
>> I think nature cares about you just
as much as nature cares about everyone else.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, that's exactly what I was afraid of.
>> Yeah. Okay so let's see, what else did we cover? So
we talked about mistake bounds as a different way of measuring things.
>> Hm. You know how many mistakes do you make as opposed
to how many samples do you need. That was kind of neat.
>> Yeah.
>> I know there's some tie-in there. And then
the bit that I like a lot is that
we started talking about version spaces and PAC learn
ability. And what really worked for me with that
was this distinction between training error which we talked about a
lot. Test error which is how we've been thinking about all
of the assignments we've been doing, and true error. And true
error in particular got connected back to, to this notion of nature.
>> Right, the distribution d.
>> Right. And then you introduce the notion of epsilon exhaustion
of version spaces, and it gave us an actual sample complexity bound
For the case of distributions in nature.
>> And the sample complexity bound is
pretty cool, because it depends polynomially on the
size of the hypothesis space, and the
target error bound and the, the failure probability.
>> Hm. So actually that reminds me, I had two questions about this one.
>> Uh-huh?
>> So, the first question was, that equation,
m greater than or equal to one over epsilon
times the quantity, natural log size of hypothesis space
plus natural log of one over delta, close quantity.
[LAUGH]
>> Assumed that our target concept was in our hypothesis space, didn't it?
>> Yes, that's true.
>> So, whatever happens if it isn't?
>> Then we have a learning scenario that's referred to in the
literature as agnostic, that the learner doesn't have to have A hypothesis
that is in the target space. And, instead, needs to find the
one that fits nearly the best of all the ones in there.
So it doesn't have to actually match the true concept. It has
to, it has to get close to the best in its own collection.
>> Okay, well, so, do we get the bounds?
>> It's very similar bound. I think, I think maybe
there's an extra epsilon, there's an extra squared on the epsilon.
>> Hm. Okay, okay.
>> And I think there's maybe slightly
different constants in here. So it's, it's
a very similar form. It's still polynomial.
It is worse though because it, the learner
has kind of less strength to depend on.
>> Okay, that's fair. Okay, so then my
second question was, I just realize staring at this
now since you wrote it in red, that the
bound depends upon the size of the hypothesis space.
>> Indeed.
>> So what happens if we have an infinite hypothesis space?
>> Well, according to this bound, The technical term is your hosed.
>> Oh, is that what
the h stand for?
>> Yes.
>> Hm, so n would be greater than one over epsilon
times the natural log of infinite which I'm pretty sure is infinite.
>> Yeah, even with the, even once you multiply it by one over epsilon.
So yeah, you know, this is a really important issue, and I think it
really deserves its own lessons. So let's, let's put this off to lesson eight.
You're right that the infinite hypothesis spaces
come up all the time. They're really important.
They almost everything we've talked about so far
in the class, like actually learning algorithms, deal
with infinite hypothesis bases, we would really like
our bounds to deal with them as well.
>> Yeah, I would like that.
>> So, I know, anything else to talk here, or should
we say, without further ado, let's move on to the next lesson?
>> I think we should say, without further
ado, let's move on to the next lesson.
>> Alright then, without further ado, let's move on to the next lesson.
>> Okay, well then I will see you next time, Michael. Sure Dan,
thanks, thanks for listening
>> Oh well, you know, I, I enjoy doing it so much.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Bye.